on l'a tout de même une certaine idée de
la liberté conditionnelle est remise en
cause par certains la réinsertion des
condamnés à de longues peines est une
opération il faut savoir très difficile
à réaliser
témoignage de l'employeur de patrick
dils patrick 10 c'est un homme qui est
défraya la chronique a quitté à son
troisième jugement après avoir été
condamné pour le meurtre de deux enfants
à montigny les metz en moselle patrick
fandio frédéric pons depuis quinze ans
est un militant de la réinsertion
marc grinsztajn emploi souvent dans son
imprimerie
quelques salariés qui sont aussi
d'anciens détenus
le dernier en date patrick dils qui a
passé cinq mois ici à sa sortie de
prison pour ce chef d'entreprise la
réinsertion ne marche pas à tous les
coups il faut certains critères il
n'aurait par exemple jamais accepté le
cas patrick henry au centre entreprise
parce que j'estime ne pas avoir les
compétences d'une telle réinsertion
profil est quand même très différent
l'acte est quand même des mesures et je
ne sais pas si psychologiquement je ne
pense pas que j'aurais pu apporter
quelque chose à perdre
sur les six détenus qui ont travaillé
ici aucun est retourné en prison
mais pour marc grinsztajn des
réinsertion ratés comme celle de patrick
henry sont toujours possibles
le système judiciaire ne serait pas
adapté ou suivi des détenus après la
prison peut-être qu'en france leur est
recherché on n'est pas assez pensé par
le monde judiciaire
parce que rien serré des gens c'est
pendant dix ans il sort de prison
on les retrouve un travail que ça suffit
je pense qu'il faut grimper un
accompagnement je crois qu'un juge
d'application des peines qui doit faire
son travail mais ya pas de psychologues
qui suivent ce genre de personnage et ça
je pense que c'est une nécessité
il espère maintenant que le gâchis de
patrick henry ne remettra pas en cause
les libérations conditionnelles dont
pourraient bénéficier ceux qui purgent
de très longues peines